-Well, you've been
doing comedy your whole life.
A lot of improv stuff,
sketch stuff.
-Yeah, sure.
-I did not know that
you dabbled in standup
in your early years.
-Yes, I had --
Standup is interesting for me,
because I've actually -- I did
a lot of it when I was younger,
and then I hit a wall
called two kids.
And most standup shows
don't start till, you know,
at least 8:00 p.m.,
and, usually,
you're on at 10:00 or 11:00.
And one night doing standup in
L.A., I fell asleep at the mic.
And I was at the mic
and I did that thing you do
when you're driving at 3:00 a.m.
And I just went...
In the middle of my jokes.
And I said, "That's it.
You can't be falling --
You can't sleep."
I had one goal as a standup.
I always thought, "You know, if
I can just entertain one person
and if that person can be me,
I'll feel good about this."
-But then, yeah,
that's out the window
if you put yourself to sleep.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Then you weren't even
succeeding on that level.
-No, no.
-We talked before on this show
about how important a show to me
"Mr. Show" was
that you did with David Cross.
-Thank you.
Does anyone know it?
It was this
obscure, little show.
-It's a wonderful show.
-Well, you can still see it.
-And then I believe it
holds up incredibly well.
-Thank you.
-Every time I think of
a "Mr. Show" sketch
and go watch it on YouTube,
I'm always thinking,
"Man, this is just as good
as it ever was."
Were you doing stuff
before that?
Were you and David
doing stuff before that
that made sense as to
what that show ended up being?
-I was.
I started in radio,
at Southern Illinois University.
And I had a show called
"The Prime Time Special."
It was on Thursday nights
at midnight.
And so it was not
in prime time or special.
And it was kind of "Mr. Show."
We had a thematic story.
My partner was
Tim Thomas, very funny,
very much like David,
in a lot of ways.
And David had "Cross Comedy,"
which was in
Boston and New York, that was
also exactly like "Mr. Show."
So we were really heading
towards that
wonderful connection.
-It is such a good
show, and I highly recommend,
for those who haven't seen it,
to go back and watch it,
'cause, like I said, it is
as good now as it ever was.
And I'm so happy
"Better Call Saul" is back.
It's such a great show.
-Thanks. Monday night.
All right.
-Monday night, everybody.
-Thank you.
-Fourth season, August 6th, AMC.